there's a few different goals but i mean
i think the primary one is to try to
refocus the united states and american
politics
on big things uh which is what we have
been doing for a long time i think for
all it's
many flaws of american policy over those
years it's been superior to the other
alternatives that have been on the table
and i think that continues to be the
case in an era of sort of rising chinese
power but upholding
certain values is important to us
holding together
as a nation and it speaks to our
international role
what's the central thesis of one billion
americans
i said the united states should take
seriously
the sort of prospect of international
competition with india and especially
china and see that the biggest edge that
those countries have
on us is their incredibly larger
population which gives
china in particular an aggregate you
know economic weight that by some
measures
already exceeds ours and by other
measures will soon
and we should act to try to grow like
literally
grow our country and become a denser
larger
more populated country and to recognize
that the current united states is
is really an incredibly sparsely
populated country
and people perceived that there would be
like some enormous burden
in tripling the population but actually
there will be a lot of
just pure domestic advantages to it yeah
for numbers
it's sort of 330 million or so at the
moment
right yeah so we're talking about about
tripling i you know i i used um
very rigorous mathematical formulas and
i i came up with nice round numbers
uh you triple what we have you get to
one billion so that's
that's science of uh book writing um so
if if you wanna if you want a technical
explanation
if the united states grew at the same
rate our population grew at the same
rate that canada's population is growing
uh if we hit that target and maintained
it we would be at 1 billion
by the end of the century wow so
canadians are just having at it
they're doing well no so canada has uh
more immigrants
than than the united states does as a
share of its population of course we
have
we have more there's nobody lives in
canada um and a slightly higher birth
rate and and you know that gets it done
and and it's a good comparison i think
because
there's more immigration to canada and
there's there's a higher level of
fertility there
but neither of them are like crazy you
know if you
walk to toronto you know it's a big city
it's an international city but you're
not like
wow this is totally different from
chicago you know it's it's just slight
tweaks to the policy environment and
they get you to a different outcome and
they get you to
i think a better outcome ultimately the
thing from
my side being british is that i really
can't tell the difference none of us can
tell the difference you have to really
know america and canada
and then you're like ah that one held
the door open for me he's one of the
canadians
like that's that's the way they eat
that's the way that you tell
um well some of them are french though i
mean i'm sure you can figure i can tell
if i can tell those or i can tell
um george st pierre if he came up to me
i'd know that it was him
uh if jordan peterson came up to me i'd
know that it was him and then everyone
else
could be it's not who is it to say the
canary in the coal mine that is the do
they open the door or not
uh what's the goal that you want to
achieve then with a billion americans
yeah i mean there's a few different
goals uh but i mean i think the primary
one
is to try to like on a high level
refocus
the united states and american politics
on big things
uh which is what we have you know been
doing for a long time for as long as
everyone who's alive today has been here
the united states has been
sort of the world's number one power you
know we
got the baton from you guys uh about a
century ago
in world war one and i think for all
it's many flaws
of american policy over those years it's
been superior to the other alternatives
that have been on the table and i think
that continues to be the case
in an era of sort of rising chinese
power
and that we should like take that
seriously as a core
part of america's national identity that
we
um you know we were joking around about
being similar to canada
but obviously one big difference is that
the united states is a major world power
and canada is not and one reason for
that is that a long time ago you go back
to
like george washington abraham lincoln
all of america's famous leaders
uh they they wanted this to be like a
major country you know and they have
different phrases for it
shining city on the hill and fdr the
arsenal of democracy
uh but it's sort of been part of our
mission i think not to
necessarily like you know when george w
bush was president things got a little
out of hand
and there was this idea that we were
gonna like conquer everyone
and make them all democracies and you
know that that's not good we shouldn't
do that uh but upholding
certain values is important to us
holding together as a nation
and it speaks to our international role
and the book is about
trying to recapture those sort of very
traditional very american
sentiments and then also just discuss
um a project that sounds a little loopy
to people
in sort of real technical terms and see
that it's it's not as loopy as it sounds
why is american not as big and rich as
it ought to be then
you are still very populous
huge in terms of actual space as well i
did a road trip
across america last year and it took
there was a day that i went through four
states
and drove for 10 hours doing like 500
miles
if i drive for 500 miles in any
direction from where i am
in the uk i'm in water like to drive
500 miles where you guys are from it's
just called a road trip
yeah it's a big it's a big country um
you know and i think traditionally right
well not just traditionally currently as
well a challenge
for america is to develop that vast
landscape to the sort of best of our
possibilities right
you look at you know people will say oh
we don't have room for all those people
um you compare
the united states to the uk um and it's
not just that the uk
is is physically smaller but it's much
denser right you have what 80 million
people
um so that's about what a
a quarter of america's population but on
a
much much much smaller land mass um
and the truth is like it's still a
really nice country you know there's
like a giant
global cosmopolitan city there but
there's also lots of nice farms
you go up north and like even in the uk
context
scotland is like virtually empty right
just like huge vast countryside
um which just goes to show it's like
there's a lot of space for people
there's a lot of
there's a lot of ways human habitation
can exist and we can have farms
and we can have wilderness and we can
have like cool mountains
uh but like just also more people in it
um and that's part of reaching the sort
of full potential that we have
both as an international player and as a
sort of modern
service-oriented economy why is it not
as big and rich as it ought to be then
given all of this land
well you know these things take time uh
obviously there was
indigenous inhabitants here once upon a
time um
largely wiped out it through some some
unfortunate incidents
recently though the united states has
taken a couple
of you know unfortunate policy turns
one is this kind of hard tilt against
immigration
which i don't i don't blame people for
thinking that the situation that
prevailed
about 15 to 20 years ago when a lot of
people were coming in
unauthorized you know that that upset
people
for good reasons i mean i i think people
feel
okay if we have rules people should be
following the rules uh but instead of
moving from that system to like a better
system in which we had legal channels
and we were selecting people in a
responsible way
but people were continuing to come we
really shut down the flow
we've been trying to terrorize under
trump you know millions of people who
are living here not doing anyone any
harm
and at the same time since 1980 the
number of children that people
are having has been going down and down
and down
and what's interesting is the number of
children that people say they would like
to have the number of children in
particular that women say they would
like to have
is not dropping right it's not that
we're seeing
some total revolution in values
and people like ah whatever who who
wants kids um
instead people are saying look uh child
care is too expensive
it's taking me a long time to achieve
financial stability
so i'm having that first child you know
into my mid-thirties
and you've run out of time they're
saying my personal finances are not
stable enough
so you know we can do things on both of
these fronts we can have an
organized legal flow of immigration that
is still at a high volume
and we can have supports for for
families with children there are deep
economic
reasons why the relative cost of child
care has gone up over time
and we just it's something societies not
just the united states
you don't need to address if they see
themselves as continuing
multi-generational
enterprises in which family life is
important aspiration
and we just sort of have to get over a
certain level of libertarianism about
these things
i saw a statistic last week tweeted out
by my friend rob henderson
that said 50 of us singletons
are neither looking for casual dates nor
a long-term relationship
fifty percent of people yeah fifty
percent of it that blows my mind
that's one of those things that makes me
wonder if people are telling the truth
yeah maybe i mean you don't know but
at the very least even if you account
for a ton of variance it's a lot of
people
it is um unless it was i don't know like
a a weirdly really
like ugly and imposing researcher
that was like so do you want do you want
a date do you want a long-term
relationship or a casual one
yeah no not from not for me not for me
i'm thinking of going into uh
into being religious religious
institutions um
is there a direct link between
population and economic prosperity then
are there not some other ways that you
could do this
um i mean i think there is a clear
relationship right i mean i think you
know
i i think for the vast majority of human
history right
we were living off the land we're
talking about hunter-gatherer bands
we're talking about little agricultural
communities we're talking about
peasant farmers and you're dealing with
a world in which
more people means less prosperity
right so there's extraordinary
statistics that will show you that
after the black plague uh wages go up in
western europe
because the worst land goes out of
cultivation
and everybody just sort of like grabs
the best farms and
you can pasture your cows instead of
needing to eat like weird black bread
all the time
um and it's great and that is so deep
in our psyche for for good reason
because that was most of human history
that people tend to think in those terms
uh but if you look at a
modern economy right what are most
people doing
um we are if we uh are privileged to be
podcasters
we're like chatting on the internet to
entertain and inform other people
uh if we're working class we are maybe
cooking food or
cleaning up or taking care of people in
a hospital setting
if we're professionals we also may work
in hospitals we may work in schools
um we might be architects but we're
we're doing things for each other
right and the more people that there are
the sort of richer deeper the market is
that we have right i've been doing you
know
i i do a podcast i've been appearing on
a lot of people's other shows we've been
doing them in english
which is great because that's the
language i speak but english is a great
podcasting medium because so many people
speak english
right that you don't need to appeal to
40 percent of the english-speaking
population to have a good show
right you can serve a niche audience it
could be
hundreds of thousands of people and
that's still a trivial fraction
of english speakers if we wanted to try
to have you know podcasts in
i don't know what danish swahili or
something yeah it's just
it's hard right it's like it's hard to
have a vibrant
uh podcasting environment in something
like that right and for in-person
services
the same is true right if you got a tiny
town
you want to run a restaurant there like
that's fine good for you
but it's going to have to be very
generic right
hopefully a nice place you know friendly
homey
but you can't specialize in one kind of
food if you've got a big city
right you can be the greatest ramen shop
in the world
right you can pick a thing and try to
excel at it
and you can have a much more productive
economy because not everyone has to
serve everything
and that's sort of modern day prosperity
but that's a very new kind of
environment and it's not the way people
are used to thinking
why is it important for america to be
number one in the world remembering i
don't have a dog in this
fight beautifully being british being
british i can play devil's advocate as
much as i want today so why why should
america be number one why is it
important
you know i think the british example
though is actually very relevant to this
right
um the united kingdom was the sort of
number one power in the world
uh for quite a while um and and that
stopped being the case
but i don't think that england's leaders
uh
and population were indifferent to that
question right
uh if if the british empire had been
replaced by nazi germany
as the world's number one power that
would have been really bad
right uh so one reason that you know
decolonization and all that process was
an acceptable outcome
for britain is that it was going to the
united states
right and if we were saying okay america
is not going to be the number one
power in the world anymore it's going to
be finland uh it's going to be the nice
canadians who hold the door
open for you you know i i might be
singing a different tune here i'm not
like a hyper nationalist
uh but you look at the real world and
what we are dealing with there
and the alternative to american
leadership is
quite a bit worse than the united states
on almost
any dimension that you want to talk
about and we see things that are
happening
domestically they've got people in
concentration camps in xinjiang
they are breaking their agreements with
hong kong regarding local democracy
there
but they're also externalizing their
political power
something that made a big impression on
me i'm a big pro basketball fan
watched the nba a lot and i saw
wow and i saw you know a coach um i
i think i think was daryl mori from the
houston rockets and he tweeted
in english in america solidarity with
protesters in hong kong
and china has already banned twitter
domestically
right so he's using a platform that's
illegal there
and the chinese cut nba
off from broadcast in china to retaliate
and then there were all these criticisms
and so lebron james says like oh he
really shouldn't have said that
and that's not because lebron is like a
like a bad guy you know he
um in u.s domestic politics has been a
real leader on a lot of issues
thoughtful person uh but you know he's a
business
too and he needs the china market
and they need him to not be critical of
anything that's happening there
so chinese speech norms are coming into
american sports leagues uh mercedes-benz
did an advertisement a few years ago and
it quoted the dalai lama about something
you know and it was something dumb right
i mean you got a buddhist monk
and they're like so buy our fancy car uh
but the chinese government threw a fit
and the ceo of daimler ends up
apologizing
for this offense that they gave to the
chinese people
and again that's that's crazy i mean why
shouldn't a german
auto executive quote the dalai lama if
he wants to
pen america this this happened after my
book came out but pen america did a
report about
chinese censorship of hollywood movies
and they said that it
started with certain things couldn't be
shown in china
or certain scenes would have to be
edited differently to go to china
but the chinese government has gotten
more aggressive and now they say
look if you want your movie to show here
you have to change it
globally and because the chinese box
office is now larger than the american
box office
movie studios do it right they change
plot points
and so um in the uh avengers movies
or doctor strange right there's a
character the ancient one and in the
comic books
there's a tibetan monk but in the marvel
cinematic universe
it's tilde swinton uh with you know a
white person uh
denationalized because disney is afraid
that all marvel distribution will be
blocked
in china if they don't do it so this is
a little bit like ticky tack stuff
movies basketball players uh but it it
speaks to the
value system of the country that we are
talking about and
it's no joke uh like bad and should be a
subject of global concern
there's some really slippery slopes that
you're at the top of there
you know you've got you've got producers
of movies on the other side of the
planet like the biggest franchise
marvel must be the it must be one of the
biggest franchises of the
you know the last sort of 10 years right
you're changing
globally changing the storyline like
which is already written
let's not forget that this isn't someone
writing a script it's an adaptation of a
comic book
right so that's a really really
good example and also quite terrifying
i'm gonna guess that you'll have seen
the uk has just rolled back the
um 5g huawei towers did you see this
i did yeah so the uk that was in
response to some concerns
some security concerns and stuff like
that so you can see how this
tit-for-tat game can escalate oh well
you did this
oh i will do that oh you did this we did
that
and i suppose as well that when you have
private companies you know if
if for some reason the avengers movie
had offended china
that well okay who pays the price for
that is there some new trade tariffs
nationally placed on america because the
choice of a private company
that's kind of crazy yeah i mean it's a
it's a difficult one
and you know you could have imagined a
different world
when i was in college i had a professor
as a
a welsh guy i think glenn morgan and he
wrote a book and it was called
the idea of a european super state uh
and and his thesis
was that american global hegemony was
unacceptable
that the united states is this like out
of control country with
religious fanatics and blah blah and you
need to supercharge
the european unification project so that
the eu
could be a global military and economic
actor
um it's a really interesting book
uh particularly from a particular moment
in time
uh in the early 2000s but we know
like world history has not gone in that
direction
right uh the uk one of the largest
european countries is leaving
and certainly the european country with
the most um
military clout and tradition of playing
on an international
stage uh there has been among the
remaining countries a a weakening of
ties
rather than a strengthening and you know
a more and more
sort of german accented europe without
the uk in it which is good in some ways
i mean there's a lot that's admirable
about
postwar germany but this is not an
entity that is going to
be a alternate beacon for
sort of freedom and liberal values um
the uk is too too small i mean right
you need much much more than 80 million
people and the other countries there's a
lot of nice
english-speaking countries out there you
know new zealand australia all very
admirable but these are
tiny tiny places so ultimately it comes
down to
american leadership um hopefully in
partnership with other countries
but american leadership or nothing um
at least as i see it i was going to say
what if you were number two behind
let's say the eu would you be so
concerned or would you even be concerned
is this how much of this is patriotic
america number one and how much of this
is anything but china number one
you know it's both i mean i i'm a
believer in america and the american
project
but it is definitely true that if we
were talking about
an increasingly integrated europe of i
don't know 450 million people
uh coming up then i think we would be
saying
i would be saying a different thing
right about what is the international
environment and we're talking about a
sort of a
a two-legged stool of global liberalism
with a different set of equities
managing that relationship uh would be
different i'm not like a
like a super ir international relations
kind of guy um
all i really know is like that is not
the world that's not the path
that we have gone down and you know one
reason that we haven't gotten down that
path is i don't think that it is in the
the nature of europe as a as a
project right it was never sold to
people
ever as like this is going to be an
international military force right
it's meant to be a project of
economic prosperity and to avoid
um intra-european conflicts right
and you know brexit obviously a very
complicated phenomenon uh but part of it
there is just
a sense i think among uh many british
people
that the project had gone beyond the
scope
of what they had intended to sign up for
right
trying to get some better export markets
suddenly you have all these immigrants
i don't know like i i like immigrants
but
it is true that like that is a different
thing um and
you know so it's not gonna happen
whereas the united states i think has
had
you know global leadership aspirations
for a long time
uh implicitly in the 19th century and
explicitly throughout the 20th century
and i think it's something that we can
rally ourselves to
and then in the opposite right as we've
sort of gone into
donald trump you know donald trump talks
a lot about greatness
right but he's really giving a sort of
little america
vision right in which we don't
participate in alliances
we don't uphold values abroad we cut off
immigration and trade
uh you know both domestically and
internationally and then you sort of
have this
ethnic conception of americanness and
exclusionary conception
and that's been a current in american
politics for a long time
but normally a minority current right um
southern segregationist politicians had
influence
uh for a long time but did not win
national elections
they did not lead the country um and
trump has
is taking us down this path to being a
kind of a lesser country
but it also pulls apart at the at the
fabric of the country
to not uphold those kind of abstract uh
ideas that can knit us together when
we're sort of at our best
getting onto the immigration point i
think this is going to be a real point
of contention for many people
to read one billion americans what is
your proposal to get from
330 to 1 billion what
how many were you going to breed how
many are we going to import
uh you know i mean i i don't think it's
an either or in a certain sense because
there's a
strong complementarities a lot of the
people working in child care are
immigrants
so what i say about immigration is just
that immigration is incredibly
underrated uh you ask normal people
about immigration i should say normal
people the median voter
about immigration um she has a lot of
concerns
you know she's not against it
necessarily but she has a lot of
concerns about economic impact about
crime about schools about all kinds of
things
you ask economists right you find the
most immigration skeptical prominent
economists in america
george borjas up at up at harvard he's
cited by jeff sessions by stephen miller
the restrictions they love him um so his
research project
he claims on a big thing that a huge
totally uncontrolled influx of cuban
refugees into miami
hurt the wages of non-cuban
hispanic people who don't have a high
school degree
right so that's not nobody but that's
like
30 percent of the population of miami 8
of the population of the united states
globally fits that view so
among experts even the restrictionists
are kind of optimistic about immigration
and among normal people there's a lot of
pessimism a lot of skepticism about
immigration
so i think the real issue is to say look
what are the most politically feasible
channels we can find
to increase the number of people who are
able to move here
um and we can't totally know a priori we
have to find it out
but one thing we do know is that when
you
select immigrants based on their sort of
education
and language skills and likelihood of
labor market success
um that's more politically popular
that's how
canada and australia have larger levels
of immigration than we do
um there's sort of detailed surveys uh
taking place in europe that show
countries with more skilled immigrants
are sort of happier with it
so i do think we should make that change
which is associated with the political
right in the united states
uh but they want to say well let's have
fewer immigrants
but make them highly skilled i say no
like let's have higher skilled
immigrants and then have
more of them right the other thing is i
think we should
be willing to an extent to cater to
people's
prejudices right if people want to say
uh i'm fine with canadians moving here
like let's open the door to canadians
right you can have free trade agreements
in goods where we don't say oh it has to
be non-discriminatory
you can pick the countries you're
comfortable with that you think will
respect environmental and labor rights
things like that
and it can be the same like we should we
should look at it you know we should uh
there's all these people living in
england and in your tiny houses
and you know ventless dryers and like
come here you know life is good
we've got ice cubes and giant sodas and
uh take big-ass road trips you know it's
amazing
um i i think you know on specific terms
i think one thing we should really do is
look at local option
for immigration which is to say there
are mayors of some cities primarily in
the midwest
that have lost population and they are
saying look we would love to have more
immigrants in cleveland
in akron in buffalo in springfield
um and we should let localities that
want to sponsor sort of extra tier of
immigrants right so if you're
the people living in the belt where they
hate immigrants
like sure okay like did the immigrants
even want to move to west virginia and
northern alabama like probably
not right to be frank about it um and
let them come to the places where
uh people see that it can revitalize
communities
that have been hollowed out by
de-industrialization and could really
benefit from
you know some of the best and brightest
people in the world moving to them
is economic prosperity worth diluting
down american culture though
so if someone is american if someone's
mexican they're not american and if they
become an american citizen that doesn't
change the fact that their culture will
be that of mexico
so if you were to import you know 100
million mexicans and then
you know a couple of million canadians
and then some cubans and all the rest of
it
you could end up being a minority within
your own country well you know but that
is america's culture right is people
coming from all kinds of different
places
i think it's reasonable to say look you
don't want to let any one particular
other place
uh sort of predominate right i mean
you wouldn't want to add i think um
300 million people from india not that
there's anything wrong with people from
india
but then it's like okay that maybe isn't
america anymore right
but if you have a bunch of people from
india and a bunch of people from mexico
and a bunch of people from the
philippines and people from africa
and people from south america right then
that's america that's the american
story once upon a time this was a
country of
english religious dissenters right
that's the sort of
original core proposition of the united
states
but we have evolved so far beyond that
so many times
big waves of immigration from germany
from ireland you know
mainstream protestants catholics come
here
um asians latin americans you know some
of my family is
eastern european jews from russia and
poland some of my family is
cuban and that's a very american
sort of family story my wife's family is
like long
time you know uh
ulster scots whatever you call them uh
you know 18th century came in
so then our sun is like even more
blended and that's
that's america like at its core is just
like a lot of weird [ __ ] coming together
downstream i can see how immigration
would then
eventually blend into a culture but
you're going to get pockets
of people the particular people from
particular countries are going to find
microcosms where other people from their
country are as well
and i can see no matter how progressive
you are with regards to immigration if
you become a minority within your own
city i can see that being very unpopular
yeah i mean look uh you know this has
always been a sort of question about
immigrant niches
um and you know i mean so i grew up in
new york which is a
very immigrant heavy city and is full of
places like that right i mean
as a sort of native born american native
english speaker i'm not a
minority quote unquote in my city but
you go to parts of jackson heights and
you're like oh
this is the subcontinent right then you
go two stops further down on the seven
train
and you're in china um and it's part of
what
you know people who love new york love
about it
uh there's also a reason lots of people
don't love new york
and you know one thing i i i want to say
is that we should
i think we should push back against the
idea
that we need to be homogenous and then
we need to exclude people
to have a successful country but i also
want to push back against
cosmopolitan liberals tendency to
deride people who have different
preferences
from theirs like it's fine
it's just a fact of life that people for
arbitrary reasons
like some people would find it
incredibly boring
to live at a very ethnically homogeneous
place because they would say
there's no good restaurants here right
love my mexican food i love my japanese
food
right and it's you know and it's the
kind of people who like like will say
like
the greatest thing to happen to britain
is that like now there's all these
indian restaurants right like it's way
better um
other people don't think that way like
some people don't like to try new stuff
they don't like spicy food and like
that's fine you know like that's that's
part of accepting diversity
is that some people don't have that kind
of cosmopolitan
hyper openness easily bored sort of
mindset
and mentality and you know i i that's
why that's one reason why having local
differentiation in immigration policy i
think can be useful and important
uh one of the things i try to show in
the book though is that there is an
economic interlinkage right that we have
seen
uh an incredible decline in the rural
population in the united states
over the past couple of generations um
and that's because
i mean it's because of several different
things but one main factor is
all throughout human history you look
thousands of years right people leave
the countryside to go live in the big
city
um but how many children are born there
in the first place
makes a big difference right if you have
three kids
and one of them moves to the big city
well you have stable population in the
countryside
if you have four and one moves to the
big city you have growth in both places
if you have two and one goes to the city
then your countryside is shrinking right
and what people are doing in rural areas
economically right is they
are engaged in primary production right
farm timber mining things like that the
market for that stuff
is in the cities right so there's a
cultural contrast between
the kind of people who like small towns
and the kind of people who like big
cities
but like i don't want to starve to death
because i have no food
and farmers don't want to be broke
because nobody is eating it and like we
really are
like in it together as a country and
having a more dynamic
more rapidly growing place both in terms
of uh you know domestic family life and
in terms of immigration
is like a win-win for everyone uh and
america has become
a lot of countries frankly but the
united states too has become so
consumed with domestic cultural conflict
that it is making it hard for us to see
what are sort of concrete like like what
really matters
right and one thing that i think is
useful
about thinking in international terms
thinking in global terms
is it helps remind us of a sort of sense
of common purpose
and togetherness and the fact that we
want to have
you know mutually beneficial
arrangements with each other
uh to defend certain things like
everybody in america like
thinks it's bad to have um
uh the stuff we were talking about
earlier you know the exporting of
chinese censorship like
nobody wants that right and nobody wants
us to be poor
nobody wants people to not be able to
raise children uh because it's
impossible to get a daycare right like
there's a lot
that we have in common and our politics
has become
incredibly focused on what
differentiates us
on symbolic levels and i think we would
be like we would be happier
in our day-to-day lives as well as uh in
our politics if we could focus on some
of the bigger picture things
totally makes sense to say that if you
can't sort your own [ __ ]
why should you be focused on trying to
import some people from a different
country
like if you guys are going absolutely
crazy at the moment
it's just pandemonium which you know
from the uk looking over it does look
like quite a lot of chaos is happening
at the moment it's like maybe
maybe you need to kind of clean the
clean the bedroom before you talk about
adding an extension on in the garage
type thing well there's something to
that um by the same token though i feel
like you know americans
have gotten so part of how we've gotten
off the rails
is people becoming so obsessed with
uh the idea that like things are
terrible here right like trump running
around talking about
american carnage um the fact that lots
of people from around the world
would like to come here uh tells us
something
right like about our own society
and its value and to sort of recognize
some of the blessings that we have
fundamentally and that it's worth
actually trying to keep them
and not just tear ourselves apart in
like a small-minded conflict about
you know the people who drive pickup
trucks and the people who drive
priuses um yeah i drive a prius i live
in a big city i
i do like i have a dog in this fight
um but like is it actually the most
important thing or conversely just to
say to progressives right um
it's obviously true that racism has
structured american society
for a long time and continues to in
important ways and people have
important claims for justice and regress
that they want to make
at the same time um people move here
voluntarily from the west indies from
latin america
from africa from asia knowing these
negative facts about american society
but also seeing a lot of positives to it
right and
when it comes to okay trump is being
cruel he's mistreating these would be
immigrants
people on the left see that that like
that's wrong that that's bad that we
should be nice to them
uh but you should also learn the lesson
of the fact that they want to come here
right that america has something
valuable to offer to the world
and that people on the right who want to
be patriotic
and want to have pride in the country
and want to say that like america
is good and we should all have little
flags in our yards um
that there's something to them right and
then to say to those people
well look if you want to be patriotic if
you want to talk about american ideals
then you have an obligation to try to
live up to them
like you yourself have not like done
anything great like as an individual
right it's like like what do we do what
are the ideas that we stand for and how
can we
sort of live them it does seem like the
messaging's got very
confused conflated i think you've got
people on the left sounding like people
on the right 25 years ago and you've got
people on the right who
i i don't even know what they sound like
anymore but you're correct like
black people in america are the most
affluent black people on the planet
like that's a reason for people from
other black countries to want to move
there
but so for me as a good example i'm i'm
british like
if i want to come to america at the
moment i can get an e2 visa and i need
to get about 150 000
together to invest into a company either
an existing one or a new one
or i need to be an o1 which is person of
extraordinary abilities
i need to be with in the top one to two
percent in my field
in the world these podcasts pretty good
but
it's it's a you know there's some big
hurdles for me to get
over there yeah am i is is the door
gonna be
easier for me to step through yeah i
mean you know one of my sort of deep
inspirations for this
was a long time ago we were launching
vox.com
uh you know we're hiring people and we
got a resume from a woman who was a
health reporter canadian born at the
time she applied
she was living in the uk like we read
her clips
uh they were really good um she had like
a good plan for coverage
so we're like all right we're gonna hire
you uh and then we like took that over
to the hr department
and they were like whoa
we got to talk about visas and in a
weird way it had never occurred to me
because
the immigration debate is always about
like mexicans
oh those people you know like
nobody is ever expressed like vocalizing
a concern
that canadian journalists too many
british people coming over here
are gonna come here from london and like
write hot takes on the internet
especially because we we have free trade
and takes
right like i i could read guardian
columns i can read
uh what's the canadian newspaper the
globe and mail like
your podcast will play in america my
podcast
plays in britain so like what's the
point even
and like who knows what the point is you
know like oh
so we got it done right we we got her an
01 visa and she is in fact extraordinary
uh but it was
it was a big pain in the ass and to what
end
like nowhere in the pain in the ass
process
was there actually like an angry
immigrant-hating person
being like america for the americans we
don't need these canadian health
reporters you know
it's just a kind of um bureaucratic
autopilot
because we cap the total number of visas
so to ease up on what should be the easy
cases
canadian health journalists british
podcasters like why not
why not right um but right now
you would have to take a visa away from
a filipino person
or a mexican or an indian american um
so that becomes its own contentious
politics right where because we've
decided to limit
the total number of visas you can't
expand the sort of no-brainers
top one percent why not top 10 percent
who would be hurt
i mean 90th percentile is pretty good
right if my podcast
was then if my book right if one billion
americans
becomes a top 10 book i'll be pretty
pleased
like that's that's good stuff we we
could use those people
i heard from a friend who got an 01 a
couple of years ago
and his attorney is one of these
absolutely [ __ ] hot
very very smart knows all the tricks in
the book attorneys and he flew
i want to say madrid so he flew to the
u.s
embassy in madrid to do that because
there's like
weird different allocation difficulty
levels
yeah yeah english guy sorry yeah english
guy
um applying to a one in america but went
via madrid
because that's the case so you're right
like this this sort of level of
bureaucracy and in
all that bureaucracy does really as far
as i see is
put a intellectual hurdle
or a cash hurdle on there because if
you've got enough money or enough smart
you can get around rules it's one of the
things i'm increasingly learning as i
get older
now all the rules are is just a problem
to be solved and if you put more rules
in the way then you select for a
particular type of people who can bend
those rules
so i don't really know and it it
expresses this kind of paranoia
about immigrants that is um visible
in in our political culture that i
looked at this uh
this legislative proposal called the
raise act that
president trump has endorsed that's
written by tom cotton
um and you know what wants to change how
the immigration system works they say
okay we want a merit-based system we're
going to select people
based on the skills and you know fine
this is not a crazy idea
um then you dive into the details and it
is so
stringent that like the uh the mvp
of the nba not to make everything about
the nba uh he wouldn't have qualified as
sufficiently skilled
because unless he could get a top 10
test of english as a foreign language
score
he needs those english language points
and you say well
why right i mean he he speaks english
okay but like it's not great
but like it's a he's a basketball player
like
it's fine that his english isn't great
plus he'll learn you know like
somebody comes here when they're 21
years old and their english is only so
so
like it'll get better there's no problem
there um or you look at
into the same thing well so you get
extra points for winning olympic medals
but only in individual sports no way
you get extra points for winning a nobel
prize but only a science prize
like all the economists aren't coming
over right or well but the literature
right like what what is the concern
like our country is going to be flooded
with nobel prize in literature winners
who are going to be what like an
excessive burden on society they're
going to drive down
the pay for our domestic novelists like
it doesn't make sense and i think if you
put it to them
they would say okay you're right right
but they're working with a mindset
that is so terrified of immigration
then instead of asking like okay what's
the real problem here
like who do we really need to exclude
they're doing the opposite they're like
let's exclude everyone and then let's
think of a couple scenarios
in which somebody could come in but look
you think about the other way okay
you don't want somebody to come who's 60
years old
and they're only going to work a couple
years and then they're going to go on
we call it social security i i don't
know what you know it's a it's a
old age pension scheme um so okay you
you want younger people to come in
um you don't want people who are going
to be totally impoverished
right or maybe you want some refugees
because that really is an act of charity
you know which is fine that's good uh
but you don't want your typical
immigrant to be somebody who's gonna
have
absolutely no wages um so that's good
okay you want people with job offers
uh you want people you know you got a
college degree like that's good
come on in uh you win a nobel prize i
don't care what nobel prize
like come on in uh maybe even if you're
just on a short list
you know booker prize shortlist come on
in right like we should be looking for
reasons to say
yes to people um it's not to say that
like you need to open the borders
of totally uncontrolled flows but just
like there's a lot of good
good people out there in the world uh
many of them don't want to come to
america a lot of people find this
country to be
off-putting in various ways uh but if
they do want to come
like that's great and that's like that's
how we got to where we are
is like all kinds of people came here i
know there's
a lot of room by vacant square mileage
but isn't there a housing shortage in
america
where's everyone going to live yeah so
this is uh here we go this is my my true
passion in life is uh nitty gritty about
housing policy
so we've got a whole chapter in the book
about this um
the you know planning paradigm in the
united states
is very localized um so these decisions
about where you're allowed to add more
houses
are made essentially on the neighborhood
level
and if you think about it there's
there's been this uh apartment
construction on my block
uh for the past year so it's just
wrapped up um
it was super annoying uh like it's
really loud
it like stirred up all kinds of rats who
started running around the block
and when it's done you know um here they
kept needing to close the street to put
cranes in
i mean all that annoyance is experienced
locally
but there's also benefits right to the
city
like more people will live here we have
a broader house uh tax base
we're gonna have a little bit more
affordability we're gonna have extra
jobs
uh but the benefits are very broad and
diffuse
and the harms are very very local so
when you make the decision
about what to allow super duper local
people err on the side of saying no to
extra houses when you broaden it out
in canada they make planning decisions
at the provincial level
in japan they do it at the national
level and so they say yes
right because you incorporate the
broader scope of interests
so we've seen some changes in that
direction
in west coast states uh just over the
past couple of years
so it hasn't had you know a huge impact
on the built environment yet
but by shifting that planning decision
up to a higher level
they are now opting in washington and
oregon and california but especially in
oregon
uh to say yes to sort of more housing
and that you know
creates the opportunities we have plenty
of space for more people
but we need a a planning paradigm that
you know makes places for them i'm going
to say the
house is going to have to come before
the immigration
you're going to have to uh well yes and
no you know it's i it's a little bit
paradoxical because uh we
immigrants work very heavily in the
building trades
get yourself over here bring it bring a
trowel and
i mean right now we're experiencing a
shortage of
uh people actually to build houses
um happening in in the us right now
because of some of some of trump's
policies
obviously that can be reworked i mean
people can retrain they can do different
things
uh but at the moment it's like we don't
have enough carpenters
which is one of the reasons we don't
have enough houses
what about second order effects then if
we can get the houses right what about
increased rent water shortages traffic
pollution overcrowding
yeah i said we've just got we've got
tons of water in this country
this is like america is a bonanza of
fresh water
so that's fine traffic is a real concern
you know a lot of cities have bad
traffic jams
um if you have way more people you're
going to get worse traffic jams
some of that is you know improving your
public transport things like that
uh but you know i think really we do
have to look
at um the sort of congestion pricing
paradigms that
they have in stockholm and oslo and
london um i think
maybe another british city uh singapore
was the sort of originator of these
things
it works well every place has been tried
it's been very
contentious at first with a lot of
naysayers and a lot of doubts
uh but it's been fairly politically
durable um
in all the european cities that have
done it you know even as parties sort of
change hands
they tweak the system you know as we
should in a democracy
but stick with it so new york is going
to implement congestion pricing soon
they have been a little bit tied up with
pandemics lately
and not all that focused on you know
commuters to lower manhattan
uh but hopefully you know when that when
the dust clears from that
you know we're gonna see that this is a
like
i have this joke it's like the only
political issue people actually care
about is
traffic and parking um they like to talk
about other things
uh so you know i get it right it's a
it's a pain in the ass to be stuck in
traffic
uh but this is also a technical problem
that has technical solutions
have you ever been to dubai no so
dubai is a uh well i went to the airport
oh everyone's been through you've got to
go through the airport you've got to go
through it i mean you can see perfect
example the airport the efficiency the
size of it the newness of it
um you can see what it's like but um i
was struck having recently been to new
york
and then going to dubai shortly
afterward i saw what happened when you
have
modern building materials a modern
understanding of traffic flow
a city which is built to get bigger not
one that you just presume is going to
stay the same size as it is now and no
new people are going to be there
and you can be doing 70 miles an hour on
a
10 lane either side motorway
and look at look on the little map on
uber and it says three minutes to your
destination and you're like
we're doing 70 miles an hour how can it
be three minutes to your destination
and then sure enough the driver pulls
off peels off at this
junction does a little loopty loop and
then deposit to you outside of the
restaurant that you're going to
because every different section has been
designed for for maximum flow for
maximum
uh volume um and then you go
to somewhere like la and you have
traffic
in different towns almost different
cities
like you can go and in san bernardino
valley be
suffering the effect of a traffic jam
that's on the coast and you're like
this can't be the what's going on
so i can see you know you add in
an extra few people people are going to
go to the popular places i know joe
rogan and everyone's doing mass
exercises out of la at the moment but
like it's going to take a little bit of
time for that to slow down people can go
new york people are gonna go to l.a
people are gonna go to dallas i think
which is like the
third most popular second most popular
city um
you're gonna that's gonna get worse and
then pollution as well
wait we'll be you know this is like this
kind of paradox right they say it's like
well nobody goes there anymore it's too
crowded right
um a guy grew up in new york
it's weird to me like it's i i find the
level of crowding there to be unpleasant
uh even though it's it's what i grew up
with um that said just like empirically
people keep going there right i i
remember i was i was pitching the
the book and you know so i i took the
train up to new york and i was in um
i was in midtown uh where my publisher's
office is
and you know midtown is the part of new
york that even new yorkers hate
[Laughter]
and they'll say well nobody goes there
um and so i'm there
and it's terrible you know like
everybody says it's terrible
because they're right but one of the
things that's so terrible about it i
mean again not now there's people
if your publisher's listening because
i've got to send this to your publishers
so when they listen
to this they're going to be saying do
you know what matthew just said on that
episode no but they're not against it
either
but it's so crowded like all these
people are there
right and so it's like well why is
everybody there right and well
we're there for each other like i was
there to have the meeting
they're there so people can have
meetings with them it's where the
transportation hubs go
uh it's where the other people's offices
are and it's great
right it's this incredible beating heart
of commerce and prosperity
uh and nobody has to be there right
you've always had the like
a book publisher i don't know they could
be in a mountain retreat someplace
uh but like that's where they want to go
and what's been limiting people's
ability
to pour into new york uh is just the
price of houses there same as london
right these
global world cities um they're almost
like uh
like black holes of uh growth and
attraction right um and like
foreign people like want to get a second
house there right so they can come and
drop by and
have their pierre terre and stuff you
know weird russian billionaires
everywhere and it's
it's kind of crazy but i mean it shows
that on some level
like more is more uh when it comes to
growth
and opportunity and things like that
even if there are traffic jams right
um so pollution you know like pollution
is a real thing like we should get
people to
drive electric cars like we know how to
do that we got to shut down coal plants
like i
i agree with all the like normal
environmentalist
stuff except that like i want to
actually do that stuff
and solve these problems and not have it
wielded as an excuse to not have a
growing economy or a growing society
uh because like they're right like this
these technologies
exists like i've got my my hybrid car
five years ago it's good
but it's like it's already outdated
today like i'm using a little bit of
gasoline the people with the chevy volts
and stuff
they're using nothing and like we can do
that we can
zip around no weird toxic fumes
i'm gonna i got solar panels on my roof
like it's
it's good like i'm uh i'm uh i say i
think i say somewhere in there that that
i'm against eco-pessimism
right but i'm but i'm for the
environment like people have
worked really hard on trying to solve
these problems and unfortunately we have
not been aggressive enough
at actually deploying the solutions that
are available to us uh
but that's like that's in keeping with
the themes of the book like we just
gotta we gotta do more stuff
it's the curse of the 20th century i
thought the 21st century
that people love a exciting
vibrant popular talking point like this
to as you say
wield like a sword in debates with
friends or
on the senate floor or whatever it might
be and you're like right okay
we've kind of got to this stage now when
when nothing gets done
you almost get bored when someone brings
it up because you know it's almost like
a signal that it's not going to happen
like the chance of the the policy is
probably made by the guy that's not
talking about it
you know the the couple that always post
their favorite couple photos when
they're on holiday together and you're
like
that relationship's breaking up that
relationship's breaking down
because it's a signal my final final
question your
um concern your primary concern is about
china
i think anyone who fully understands
the sort of threat that they pose quite
rightly is concerned about that
in terms of population i had a look at
the chinese academy of social sciences
a study that they recently did at start
this year said that
china is facing its most precipitous
decline in population in decades
and that china will be back under 1
billion by 2100
and there's there's huge swaths of
millions of men that are single
childless and have no way to have a
family
that's the dream i mean
that's this is what i'm saying we're at
2100
we're going to be at a billion they're
going to be under a billion
and that's it america number one forever
um
but this is serious i mean i i think
it's you know it's worth looking at
the way they are thinking about this in
china right they had this one child
policy era
uh which people know of some of the
cruelty that was involved with that
uh but the extent to which the chinese
policy community
now views that as a huge mistake that
has given them
this kind of yeah they they now have
this um
demographic momentum right toward
incredible aging and population
shrinkage
and some of that is the legacy of the
one child era
but some of it is just the knock-on
effect right so you're talking about
people who have very few cousins
people who don't have a sister who can
help out with the kids
right people who uh can't find a wife
because this is amazing i think it might
be in the washington post that wrote
this
unbelievable article that broke down or
like
very personal stories about all of the
different men and then some really cool
sort of animated statistics and things
as well
but i remember i remember seeing that
that there's a there's like a fat
a fat bit in the graph that's slowly
reaching like i think it's maybe at the
20 late 20s to 30s now and this is the
age of
some of the women that are in china and
this big fat bit of the graph is going
to pass 40 and then you're correct
there's
there's not a whole lot that can be done
i mean it's really screwed up and you
think about how normal
families operate right you assume you
know look dating is hard right
but you assume that like mathematically
there's somebody out there for me
right not like not like no literally
there isn't
right yes that's like that's like we
would say now if your friend he's
depressed he's like oh i'm never going
to meet a girl
and we'd say no no yourself but in china
you're like no actually you won't
i'm very sorry that's not good and
people rely on extended family networks
for support when they have young kids at
home
if that doesn't exist it's very
disruptive and
you know i mean i think on one level i'm
glad that they're hitting some problems
uh
on another level though it's very sad
you know when you
hope they can find a way to do better um
this is of course one reason why it's
not
you know good to have a totalitarian
system of government because
like a bad idea does not get fully aired
in a discussion sharpen zion when it
comes to this sort of stuff right yeah i
mean it's it's good you know uh
it's easy i you meet people sometimes
he'll be like
oh i just went from laguardia to the
awesome new airport in beijing and it's
like
why can't we have a dictatorship that
just cuts off problems and gets things
done
but like sometimes when they get done
it's like really
really bad um and it is good to have a
discussion and debate about ideas
because the legacy of that particular
idea i mean
it was bad in its moment and the long
term it's just
it's hard to fix have you considered
portioning off a bit of alaska
and just taking loads of chinese people
there because that fixes both of your
problems
at once yeah there's always interesting
you know alaska things i i don't know if
you know that michael chabon's novel
um the yiddish policeman's union but
it's basically like alternate history
like what if they what if they had just
kind of built israel in alaska right
right as a
as a refugee ship on it it's this idea
that always kind of recurs to people
because alaska's just sitting there big
and empty
yeah um and i do think it's appealing i
mean i would have to talk to some
alaskans
see what's going see what's going on
yeah exactly wasn't donald trump going
to buy greenland at one point
yes uh the possibilities of greenland
are
are quite large um you know so uh so i'm
all for it i
i think you know by we got
i think originally we tried to buy
greenland uh about a hundred years ago
and we took um what's now the u.s virgin
islands instead
uh [ __ ] deal that was [ __ ] that was the
deal did no one think
shouldn't it go that was could have gone
that was the deal that danes made with
us but
you know i so i originally had a chapter
about like well maybe we should
have an accession process like the eu
and you know maybe jamaica will become
the 51st state uh
we wound up cutting it because it was i
don't know i couldn't really work out
the details
to my satisfaction uh but it's an
interesting idea fun to think about
got you matthew thank you very much for
today man one million americans
will be linked in the show notes below
anywhere else that people should go to
check your stuff out
uh you know i'm on vox.com i'm on
twitter
maddie glacious um love to see you there
awesome thank you so much for your time
man
thank you thank you